well now I guess you know meant when I said that
Texaco has got a real knack for getting up ads
that put over a story but what about radio well I
tell you nothing new when I remind you the Texaco
Scott Fred Allen this year so when it comes to
radio advertising brother there's no sweeter sound
comes to me in my neighborhood then the Texaco
star dealers coast-to-coast welcome you to an hour
of mirth and melody with our star comedian Fred
our Kenny Baker and Portland Hoffa it's Texaco
time and gentlemen there is a doctor in the house
a physician who without anesthetic sets your body
bone tickles your ribs and splits your side and
here he is that in turn of entertainment Fred
Allen in person thank you thank you and good
evening ladies and gentlemen say Jimmy why
does this program always have to open with such an
elaborate announcement for me now I don't need all
of that billing just mention my initials that's
plenty we could save all that time yes but Fred
we've got to make the opening impressive whom are
we impressing Jimmy now let's get the show started
that's the main thing you know if we have a long
opening we have to rush everything at the end
of the program to get it all in now last week you
remember at the end of the show why I was talking
so fast I got 20 Lucky Strike fan letters people
thought I was a tobacco auctioneer well maybe we
can open the show like the president opens a new
highway or a tunnel or dam well how do how does he
do that and he just pushes the button on his desk
well that may be a little quicker James but it is
also a little more dangerous dangerous how do you
mean well last week the president was supposed to
open a bridge in Salt Lake City he pushed the
wrong button and opened two Republicans in the
Mayo Clinic now never mind the explanations James
let's get on with the show and now ladies and
gentlemen I ain't what's working well everything
is perking but the program Kenny I'm trying to get
things started now you know we've got newsreels
tonight guest stars music oh by the way while I
think of it Kenny I have been watching you lately
do you have to keep playing with that yo-yo all
through the program every night you know if I have
to keep looking up and down following that yo-yo
any longer I'll have to get my eyes marfa well
confidentially Fred yo-yos are for little kids
well what were you doing with that one tonight
we're breaking it in for baby sandy no with me
it's a business oh you've got a yo-yo tire and
how the biggest yoyo company in the country is
letting me use this yo-yo if I mention it on the
so every week for a year yes yes yo-yos mine Kenny
look you are no longer with mr. Benny now you
don't need any sidelines here on this program
we are paying the living wage so I tell you what
you do you get that yo-yo off the premises put
it back in your boy scout kid herself oh but I'm
practicing a terrific trick fa a trick with the
yo-yo yes I jump in the air click my heels and
where are your you're around my ankles Oh wait'll
I show it to you it's fun now look Kenny oh this
I'll kill you FA the honk get up on the bandstand
here now wait a minute Kenny I don't care to see
the trick you know this isn't hellzapoppin ladies
and Jeff I'm sorry to have to announce that the
tenor who was scheduled to appear with us on the
program this evening will not be able to appear
while the damage to the studio is being repaired
that's right what is it for there's a man outside
who says well why not now I'm sorry can't you see
I'm busy tell the gentlemen to come back later
now ladies and gentlemen mr. Allen one man our
sponsor well that's impossible our sponsors are
more than 45,000 Texaco dealers B Fred and all
them fellas out there there are 45,000 of them out
there well I'll have to count them later well I'm
very happy to meet you sir mr. dealer and thanks
a lot for dropping in well Fred I just wanted to
meet you personally and tell you what a swell job
you're doing for me well I'm glad you feel that
way sure but I'm working for more than 45,000 men
like you how is it you feel so deeply you know I
mean as though I'm doing it all just for you it's
like this Fred you see a feller like me well I'm
always doing a lot of things to make Texaco
mean just me to the folks in the neighborhood
and so everything that you do under the Texaco
sponsorship to make their lives of those people
more enjoyable well that makes them like me more
and all that you and Larry Elliott and Jimmy
Warrington say about Texaco products and services
well that just means that much more profit coming
in for me and my family so that's fine as a
personal in my gratitude well thank you a lot
sir I tell you what you just keep pumping your gas
at the Texaco service stations I'll try to do the
best I can with my gas here at the broadcasting
station and I'm sure everything will be alright
alright yes sir the Texas company folks sure
give us a breadwinner when they turn him loose
in our neighborhoods for us every week and on
top of that nine if they don't wanna sponsor
the biggest serious musical program on the air the
big metropolitan opera series with the lineup of
guest speakers to talk on the American Way that
includes some of the finest people in America
folks around my neighborhood that would rather of
missed a meal and to a miss the Metropolitan Opera
broadcast on Saturday afternoons maybe you wonder
what I meant when I talked to Fred Allen like that
about Texaco meaning just me two folks in my
neighborhood laughter eyes over to net billing
store that day realized that all them magazine ads
and billboards and radio programs actually reached
every family in the neighborhood if suddenly
come to me but all that advertising could be
my advertising just as much mine as though I hired
Fred Allen myself to entertain my neighbors just
as much as I wrote them ads and put him out myself
from the neighbors to read that's what Matt did
remember him and that moving picture last year max
tired from scratch hoods just a dump of a place
nobody's stopped at built up a pretty fine station
with a lot of good customers they didn't all come
rushing in the minute he hung up a Texaco sign
not by a long shot some of them did sure but the
rest of the customers he got came because he did
everything he could to tie in with the advertising
he printed up handbills with his name and location
on him gave him out all around his neighborhood
remember and he sent out Texaco mailing pieces
with his own name and address printed on him and
he went around and asked folks to trailer folks
who were sold but Texaco advertising but just
hanging fire he went right out and talked about my
effect and asked folks to let him artifact their
car at his station well fellas when I finally
woke up I decided to do the same thing I went
after my folks in the same way made those Texaco
ads my aunts made a mean me and I got me dozens
of customers and hundreds of dollars that was
just hanging fire in my neighborhood so brother
you're looking at one feller who's maybe going to
be just a little bit hoggish about it because if
there's a boom going on and there's a cake being
passed around here's one feller who's gonna cut
himself a big slice I'm going after new customers
this year twice as heavy because I know there'll
be a lot of folks in my neighborhood with cars
that didn't happen before and there'll be plenty
of others who trade in their jalopies for good
secondhand cars or new ones and then there'll be
folks whose opinion about being satisfied with
where the trade they'll change a lot there's
their pocketbooks well a bit this isn't going
to be anybody in my neighborhood we install by
those Texaco ads every week and just hang fire no
sir I'm really bearing down this year let me show
you operator show us some of those mailing pieces
and things will you please these here this year's
spring and fall mailing pieces fellows not the
sames we've been in the past to say I mean good
selling top and all written up in the same lingo
on colors it's all that advertising and I want
to hook up with by having my own name signed
to it there's even some new wrinkles now that
maybe even gives these an edge over last year
like this follow-up for peace to be in a kind
of Christmas card combination there's special
mail in pieces too for any you fellows who are
just switching to Texaco or taken over a station
or starting a new one seems to me if I was just
new in a neighborhood this is the first thing I'd
want to do to get the personal benefit of Texaco
advertising and now let me tell you something
about the window displays remember Les Paul the
advertising theme of danger cold weather ahead
that was put over sis well in all the ads and
remember how we had a window display at the same
time the tide ride in used the very same theme
and the same pictures and everything well sir me
and so many other fellas was so tickled with that
idea of tying right in with the ads while they
were running that the Texas folks are gonna do
that with all the winner displays that that can
this year talk about making the advertising me
me that's gonna be hit I mean when the displays
like that or really do the job because they'll
make it possible for me to bring to life right
my own station all the very same things that's
in the ads and the Texas folks are making them all
up now in two types for Windows like mine that are
under five feet wide or for Windows that's over
five feet we're talking about the sizes of windows
let me tell you I got to figure in lately what my
window will do for making the ads my ads my whole
station will do what is my station two folks
one great big display you look at it that way
you'll most likely find like I did there's a
couple of signs and things you've been using
and you'll get them up quick before anymore this
boom here goes by maybe you're forgetting to bring
the advertise to life for you those little things
they're just between you and your customers I'm
pouring it on him this year fellas I got me such
a supply of all these things you didn't think I
was running a County Fair or something and seeing
those road maps remaining polynomials and often um
Texas coast torrent service will get him friendly
and solid life that makes him your customers and
that's just one more thing that Tex goes got for
you when me too used to make all that advertising
means you would be it's a lot of customers if you
use it right but getting back to reaching out for
new customers there's one thing that I cried out
last year just once sort of experimental like
and I'm going in for it real heavy this year this
screen advertising the Texas folks has got for us
that we can have runoff at our local movie house
I tell you fellas when your name comes up there
on the screen I mean it's a thrill I got so much
comment from folks made me feel like a big shot
that they're sure made Texaco advertising mean
me and my neck of the woods no mistake about that
tell us it's pretty hard to think of one single
thing this profitable in any retailing or service
business that Texas people ain't made up and got
ready for us to use anytime we want and on top of
that this stuff that they can't exactly make up
like business building schemes and merchandising
ideas they collect burn them up send them to us
to read every month I don't know what you fellas
do with your copy of the Texaco dealer but if
it ain't the dog-eared like mine from reading
over and over I may be overlooked one of those
things that put money in the bank for well maybe
fella sitting right next to you because that's
where the ideas come from fellas like you and me
who think I'm up try them out get money out of
them let me give you a tip make this boom here
the realist try out mist year of your whole life
in the business Mexico people are doing all they
can for us more all that advertisement all that's
it you saw I can't do the job alone no sir it's
up to you me to put it to work work for us so
make that Texaco advertising you're advertising
make it mean you to folks and I promise you you'll
have a swell feeling especially round the pocket